قال المتحدث باسم الاتحاد التونسي للشغل
السامي طاهر ان المظاهره النقابيه المقرره
غدا من امام مقر الاتحاد مفتوحه لكل من له
غير على البلاد حسب تعبيرهم واضاف الطاهر
في تصريحات ان الحكومه اغلقت ابواب
المفاوضات والحوار وتعمل عمدا على اغراق
المؤسسات العموميه حسب تعبيره كما شدد
الطاهري على ان الحكومه الماضيه في تنفيذ
تعليمات صندوق النقد الدولي والطبقه
الوسطى تدمرت وتراجعت في مستوى المعيشه
وفق قوله
هذا وكان السلطات التونسيه رفضت السماحه
لجبهه الخلاص المعرضه بتنظيم احتجاجات احد
المقبل بدعوى شبهه التامر ووصفت الجبهه
القرار بمنع التظاهر بانه تعسفي وباطل
واكدت انها لن تستجيب للقرار من جهتها دعت
حركه النهضه انصارها وكل القوه الحيه في
البلاد حسب وصفها الى التظاهر السلمي يوم
الاحد واستنكرت ما وصفتها بمحاوله التضييق
وبث البلبله وقد شجبت احزاب ومنظمات
استهداف المعارضين والمنظمات الوطنيه
واعلنت المشاركه في المسيره التي دعا
اليها اتحاد الشغل غدا السبت